foreign
[Music]
tricks can be a lot of things they can
be beautiful they can be elegant they
can be complicated and they can be
really difficult Drex here from Drex
Factor POI sharing with you the love of
poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I am
sharing with you my picks for the five
most difficult POI tricks that I have
ever learned but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrotera light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
becklenen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so like real talk in the time that I've
been spinning poi there have been tricks
that I have learned that came more or
less easily or once I understood the
concept it just came together for me and
there have been some poetrics that I
just chipped away at for months if not
years and quite frankly what those
tricks were depended quite a lot on
where I was in my POI Journey lots of
tricks that I now consider to be
relatively easy for me were quite
challenging for me back at the beginning
of my POI Journey so I wanted to create
a list that reflected how I have evolved
over time and I'm sure how many of you
all out there do as well so this list is
not going to be an inventory of what I
think the five hardest poetrics are out
there currently in the world but really
the five POI tricks that gave me the
most trouble as I was going through my
POI Journey after all difficulty is a
really relative thing and I think it's
really important that we recognize how
hard it is for people at all stages of
their journey to learn new things so
with all that said I'm going to start
this list off with the first POI trick
that ever gave me trouble and
what a coincidence it's also the first
POI trick that I ever learned
number one POI reels
[Music]
yeah so this one's still a little bit
shameful to me but when I took my first
lesson as a POI spinner the first thing
that my teacher Paul salty ever tried to
teach me was how to do basic together
same reels turning from forwards to
reverse and back again and over the
course of a two hour lesson I absolutely
failed to wrap my head around this and
get it down part of what was going on
for me is just I thought for some reason
that the two POI stayed in two separate
tracks the entire way around it didn't
dawn on me until weeks later that you
actually bring the POI together into the
same track in order to get them to go
back and forth across your body and I do
just want to highlight this one because
it nearly ended my POI career before it
even started I was so disappointed in
myself not being able to get this one
trick at the start that I actually gave
up and I told myself that POI wasn't for
me if not for the timely intervention of
another friend who gave me a set of poi
as a gift I don't know that I ever would
have picked them back up and I I think a
lot of people including myself would
have missed out on a lot for that so
while this is a trick that I think many
of us take for granted including myself
I also think it's important to highlight
just how important this was to my
personal evolution
trick number two crossers
okay so in those first two years when I
was spinning poi I remember picking up a
lot of things relatively quickly you
know once I had a group of people to
hang out with and like trade tricks back
and forth with it seemed to go much
faster learning but there was this one
trick that I kept seeing that in the
back of my mind I knew this is going to
be a major Challenge and actually
avoided it for a couple years for that
reason that trick of course is crossers
I first saw my friend Kyle doing this a
Confluence Park back in Denver and
somehow I just knew watching it that
this move was going to require me taking
weeks if not months worth of work to
figure out the basic steps that go into
it like it was really clear that
regardless of how long an explanation
there was for the trick there was a
basic skill at play here that I was
going to have to work at for a while it
was going to be new information for my
body and a new understanding that I was
going to have to integrate into muscle
memory
I knew that that work was coming for me
and I just did not want to do it and
then finally I took the plunge I spent
weeks drilling spinning the POI with my
arms crossed both forwards in Reverse I
drilled turning back and forth between
these two positions it took me weeks it
took me months but you know what I did
finally get it this was the first trick
that I truly had to work for and it will
always occupy a special place in my
heart for that reason
trick number three isolation versus
horizontal cation
yeah so I know there's a massive leap in
difficulty between the first two tricks
and these latter three tricks but bear
with me here horizontal cat eye versus
isolation was probably my first claim to
fame as a tech POI spinner at a time
when there were less than a dozen people
in the entire world that could do it I
was able to put it together within my
first three years of spinning and it's
wild to me because while many of the
tricks that I found difficult in those
first few years of spinning poi have now
become more or less commonplace this is
the one that remains super rare and that
I see people struggling with more than
any other and I get why because all of
the elements of this trick are
incredibly difficult first up there's
the anti-brid element which that's a
whole thing that people have to train
their brains and bodies on number two
the isolation people take months if not
years to learn how to do clean
isolations just in themselves and
finally the horizontal cat eye literally
the Mount Everest of the cat Eyeworld
you're putting all of these pieces
together
yeah it's not an easy time and yet I
still think this is one of the coolest
looking tricks that I have ever picked
up and one that I still love to pull out
to brag on occasion
trick number four the one-handed
Mercedes
so real talk 2.1 hand like learning how
to spend two POI is one meteor
is one of the most frustrating things
I've ever picked up in my time spinning
poi it took months upon months of
unbelievably frustrating work and the
Mercedes was something I said as a goal
for myself very early on in that process
at a time when I was pulling at my hair
even learning how to do basic one-handed
weaves and waist wraps this was where I
knew I wanted to get to like no lie I
can remember afternoons practicing this
where I would get so frustrated that I
would literally just beat the POI
against the ground I would spend hours
and hours and hours just continually
having the POI whack against each other
not being able to figure out how to get
the planes where I wanted them to be
and then magically one day the pieces
came together for me okay that's a bit
of an exaggeration it worked once and
then it took me a while to get it to
work again and then finally it became
like second nature this is now one of my
favorite tricks to pull out when I'm in
a two-poi one hand kind of place and
still to this day it's one of the most
common things I get asked how to teach
alright so we are down to our last trick
on this list and that means that I gotta
ask a favor of you if you've been
watching this long it probably means
that you're into POI tricks and guess
what I post lots of videos about those
so if you've been enjoying this video
pretty please give me a subscribe leave
the video a like it helps out the
channel and it helps make sure that you
get to see all of my new videos as soon
as they get uploaded and now coming in
at number one the most recent POI trick
I've learned that absolutely drove me
crazy with this difficulty is
number one Gunslinger anti-spin flowers
so I first encountered Gunslingers years
ago when Jonathan Alvarez moved to the
Vulcan in Oakland California
but I didn't really feel a great need to
learn the basics of it or even get
terribly deep into it either and then
all that changed when AOE kondo posted a
video of himself performing Gunslingers
as anti-spin flowers and instantly I was
not only hooked but also more than a
little bit terrified because I knew I
had a lot of catching up to do and
catching up I did because start to
finish and learning how to do this trick
it probably took about like five to six
months worth of work and at every step
of the process I kept discovering new
basic information I needed to train my
body on in order to get there figuring
out how to learn the trick was almost as
difficult as learning to do the trick
itself but hey I think the work was
worth it don't you this to this day is
one of my favorite poetrics and quite
frankly probably the single hardest
thing that I know how to do at this
point and it's also something that I
take immense Pride at having stuck with
and figured out how to get from
beginning to end so that was my list of
the top five most difficult POI tricks I
have ever learned what would be on your
list what were the POI tricks that gave
you the most trouble as you were getting
into your POI Journey at all steps of
that Journey I'd love to know leave me a
comment
foreign
would not be possible word not for the
kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helped to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you all so very much for your very
generous support and if you're out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there's a
link to do that down in the description
as well as up in the cards if you are
watching this video on YouTube go take a
look at that please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out some of the
other videos I've done in my series of
top five POI tricks of various sorts I
will include a link to that playlist
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you're watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here because it is popular amongst
my other viewers so maybe give that a
look as well thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
peace